دعني ابدا معك
بكونك عملت مع خمسه رؤساء من ضمن ابرز
قاده العالم وعملت كذلك مع خمسه عشر وزيرا
للخارجيه كما انك تعد احد ابرز وجود
دبلوماسيه الاوروبيه في العقود الثلاثه
الاخيره على حد ما وصفتك به صحيفه
اللوموند الان وانت تعيش التقاعد كيف ترى
العالم هل يشبه ما توقعته عن مغادرتك
الدبلوماسيه
الكثير من الامور حدثت بعد مغادره
الدبلوماسيه عندما دخلت الى عالم
الدبلوماسيه في عام
1978 كان انذاك عهد اريجان الذي انتخب
وكذلك مارك
وكان عهد دخومين ايضا وصول الى ايران كان
لامبر يتعلق بدنشو بينك في الصين الذي كان
لديه برنامج اصلاحات وبعد اربعين عاما نرى
اننا وصلنا الى نهايه دائره العالم يعيد
تنظيم نفسه واعتقد اننا اليوم في مرحله هي
النفس ليس نفسها بدات في الحرب البارده
عرفت نهايه الشيوعيه كان هناك الكثير من
المراحل مثل الربيع العربي والازمه
الماليه فالعالم يشكل نفسه من جديد
نزوع العالم نحو هذا الوضع من التوترات هل
بسبب افتقاده الى قاده مثل جاك شيراك الذي
اشد به ايما اشاد في كتاب مذكراتك
اعتقد ان سمت الكثير من العناصر عنصر
الرجال هو احد العناصر ولكن كما قلت
العالم تغير بشكل كبير نعيش في عالم بعد
الحرب العالميه الثانيه اسس على قواعد
دوليه مع وجود الامم المتحده التي انضمت
اليها غالبيه الدول لكن الجهات الفاعله
تغيرت وهناك ايضا ما اسميها تحول
الاجيال وجيل اليوم ليرى العالم من منظور
مختلف اما كان عليه لما يوجد اليوم بلدان
لم تكن موجوده على الساحه في السنوات
الستين او سبعين الماضيه هناك دول حازت
استقلالها وهذه مساله مهمه هناك بلدان
ناشعه افكر في بلدان الكبرى مثل الصين
والهند وهناك ايضا عوده لتركيا
وهناك دول في الشرق الاوسط المملكه
العربيه السعوديه الامارات العربيه
المتحده في افريقيا نيجيريا هذه الدول
الكبرى تريد ان تجد موطعه قدم لها وهي
مساله مهمه في العالم تغير بشكل جذري